samsung just unveiled its new galaxy
flip 4 and fold 4 smartphones
and while the foldable category has had
a rocky past four years later samsung
the world's largest smartphone maker
says that they've never been better or
more durable but what you might not know
is phone makers already have ideas for
how to make designs that are even more
flexible
like what if your phone could roll into
whatever size you wanted and that all
begs the question are flexible screens
just a gimmick or are they actually here
to stay i went to samsung's showcase in
new york to get an early preview and
find out if i could answer those
questions samsung says it has focused a
lot of attention on the durability of
these foldable phones that's because
when it first came out in 2019 reviewers
noted that there were some problems with
the hinge and screen protector which
looks like you're supposed to peel it
off but you aren't well samsung quickly
addressed the initial criticism and now
says the new versions use an even
stronger adhesive to attach the screen
protector the company has also
strengthened the area around the crease
in the middle for added support because
of this samsung says the flip 4 and fold
4 have a front panel that's 45 stronger
than previous models the fine tuning
shows how invested samsung is in the
category but foldables are much bigger
than any one company rivals lenovo
huawei and others have also released
foldable devices
prices play a major role in how many
people actually buy foldable phones when
the fold first launched it cost about
two thousand dollars and was much too
expensive to appeal to the masses it now
costs eighteen hundred dollars still
significantly more than apple's flagship
iphone 13 pro max which costs a thousand
ninety nine bucks
as for the flip it launched at thirteen
eighty and is now selling for a thousand
analysts told me that the price drop
helped samsung appeal to a lot more
people and sell a lot more units the
company held 88 of the foldable market
last year with the galaxy z flip 3 and z
fold 3 being the most popular devices
globally
and the number of foldable phone options
continues to grow rivals xiaomi oppo and
lenovo have also made foldable phones
while apple the main holdout holds
patents for foldable phones no word on
when or if it'll actually come out but
the number of foldables sold still
remains low when you compare them to
smartphone sales overall foldables make
up less than one percent of the market
analysts told me that foldables will
likely remain niche for years to come
and not replace the bar shaped phones
we're all used to seeing at least not
for the foreseeable future because while
you can get phones like this at
virtually any price point foldables like
this require special parts that make
them more expensive phone makers are
also looking for ways to bust out of the
old rectangular phones we're all used to
seeing and more flexible screens allow
companies to figure out where demand
truly lies
whether you're willing to shell out
eighteen hundred dollars on foldable
screens or not they kind of force you to
think about the future and what might be
next we don't know if it's foldables
rollables or something we've never seen
yet but change in trying something
different is what brought us the iphone
so perhaps reinventing the displays
we're all used to seeing maybe that'll
give us the next big thing
[Music]